[Music]
obviously you could do a lot with cg and
everything could be kind of a green
screen movie what we're trying to do and
what i've always found take something
that makes it extra special is to take
something and have as much real as
possible in the frame
how do you invent gotham for real how do
you prep gotham for real and that led us
to
improving our technology the city of
gotham is a character in the movie and
so you're like how do we really like how
do we do this for real and
if you want to do it with the best
quality to make it look real you want to
avoid anything that looks like you know
bad visual effect shots
we're using the led volume we're trying
to do as much in camera as possible now
that's still using new technologies
but the goal is to create as photo reel
and experience as we can so greg frazier
is lighting with practicals the light in
the set is coming from the set itself by
and large it's a huge movie so there's
big extension
having done this before on another show
i saw the power of this very early on
and it's a positive for the final viewer
when something is shot in camera by
pushing the technology along on batman
warner brothers going to make it more
accessible to the next dp that does the
next show
this is one of those things that has to
be done this way because you can't go
back in terms of progress when you've
seen
something perform as well as it can to
move backwards onto a traditional blue
screen stage feels to me like it's not
doing justice to the batman that's one
of the big advantages with the led
stages you can essentially freeze time
you can
put up a you know golden hour sunset and
you can have that sunset last as long as
you need while you're doing the
photography when you're shooting you
know out on location you'll shoot a
bunch of stuff one direction at sunrise
you shoot a bunch of stuff the other
direction at sunset just so that the
lighting is better on the actor's face
depending on which direction they're
facing with the led setup you can you
know you can spin the world you can spin
the sky hold the world stationary so
we're making a lot of advancements in
terms of how robust we can make this
technology having these panels work in
the rain is only possible by pushing
that envelope and that's certainly
something that we've been excited to be
a part of
it was exciting to work in the volume
because you feel like you're at the
forefront of something the volume work
that had been done had been in desert
scapes not in cityscapes and so the idea
of virtually creating a city and james
working hard with the artists to try and
lay out this city in a way that felt
really signature to us
it was an opportunity to see gotham the
animal that is the city the character
that is the city you know perform for us
help me out man
shut up not that way there is no other
way he owns the city you know me and rob
had this emotional scene on the on a
roof and to really have the cityscape it
was a game changer it was incredible
what they were able to do all that stuff
took months and months of planning
inside a computer or game space before
we started building
it allows us to make the the entirety of
the set more real makes the lighting
more real makes the photography
ultimately look more real in addition to
the benefit that it gives us from a
technical standpoint you've also got the
the rest of the environment there so the
actors can experience the space as
they're driving the cars they can react
to what they're what's coming at them on
the screens
i got you
you